[Music]
really theta ETA Aquos battler stand out
Becca Martinez at the shows women tell
all reunion special taping and we told
her that almost bachelor Peter Krause
had his eye on her out of this season's
contestants when watching it is there
anyone you'd be interested in both the
Becca's actually seem like really great
people I interviewed Peter just a couple
weeks ago and said have you been
watching the show and in picturing what
it would have been like if these were
your ladies and he said yes and I am
very into both of the Becca's so really
said that if you want to maybe slide in
the video you're just hilarious because
I've been joking around I'm like well
thank God it was Ari cuz I wouldn't have
lasted past week two with Peter I've
seriously been saying that I'm like I
think Peter would have sent me home like
I do I think not will you reach out some
trinkets lots of offers on a daily basis
so here's the thing
Becca actually went to a bachelor
casting call just for Peter even though
she did end up connecting with Ari Lions
like jr. before heap sent her home
well we're people surprised when
everybody got there and found out it
wasn't Peter yes I think it was
surprising I'm not gonna lie when I
watched rachel season I was like wow I
can actually see myself with Peter and I
have never I've watched the show for so
long and I I'm not joking when I drove
to the casting call I was hungover I'd
been up until four o'clock in the
morning the night before and I was
driving to Orange County and I'm like
business for Peter it was Ari I was kind
of like well I don't know who the hell
this is but it's gonna be meeting a
stranger like anywhere else you know
I've met boyfriends at the gym you know
through friends at a bar whatever so
it's like wow I'm gonna meet a stranger
on TV and just see what happens so it's
kind of cool
you